bueno como decíamos y como era de
esperar el oficialismo en rusia estaría
ganando estas elecciones legislativas
pero como analiza usted los resultados
de momento para el partido comunista que
según trascendió estaría ganando un poco
más de terreno
buenas tardes gracias por la invitación
efectivamente el partido comunista
quizás va a ser el mayor triunfador de
estas elecciones
legislativas en rusia porque su
resultado es mayor de lo que está
esperado y una de las posibles
explicaciones porque a los comunistas le
fue mejor expresamente porque la
propuesta del líder de oposición
aleccionaban y que se encuentra en la
cárcel estaba dirigido hacia el apoyo de
los candidatos alternativos a rusia
unida iu a través de una herramienta que
se llama la el voto inteligente nava le
estaba recomendando a votar por
cualquier otro candidato que no sea del
partido oficialista rusia unida y
aparentemente esto dio sus resultados
ahora teniendo en cuenta estos
resultados para el partido comunista
cree usted que esto podría de alguna
manera sentar cierto precedente para que
la oposición pueda hacer frente con más
fuerza de ahora en más al gobierno de
vladímir putin
yo creo que todo depende de los
resultados finales porque todavía
nosotros estamos hablando de los
resultados preliminares si el partido
rusia unida no logra tener la mayoría de
los votos les va a tocar negociar con en
la segunda fuerza política más
importante que son comunistas y haya yo
creo que los comunistas puede tener un
espacio de maniobra bastante amplio para
poder realmente promocionar la agenda
que no necesariamente corresponde a la
gente que quiere hacer el gobierno de
vladímir putin entonces yo creo que sí
tenemos una entrega todavía por lo menos
hasta mañana cuando vamos a conocer los
resultados finales ahora sí se considera
como muchos analistas hacen no a estos
comicios como una suerte de referendo no
de cara a las elecciones presidenciales
de 2024 qué escenario prevé usted para
el actual presidente vladimir putin
claramente el parlamento ruso quizás no
es un actor político más relevante más
importante sin embargo no debemos
olvidar que el año pasado cuando fue la
votación por los cambios en la
constitución rusa no fue la votación por
una nueva constitución los cambios
fueron a la constitución existente y el
órgano político induce que puede
realmente cambiar la constitución de
nuevo y será tan posibilidad o la
oportunidad sería el parlamento ruso que
se elige en estos tres días entonces
para mí entrar a puesto es para las
próximas elecciones presenciales tal
como decíamos también se han denunciado
múltiples irregularidades tiene usted
constancia de algunas de éstas
si efectivamente nosotros somos testigos
de muchas irregularidades
que fueron reportados por los
observadores independientes fueron en
muchos casos filmados transmitidos en
directo en el internet
el órgano que está encargado en vigilar
las elecciones en la comisión central de
las elecciones re consciencia reconocido
solamente una parte de estas
irregularidades entonces yo creo que en
estos días vamos a ver un informe más
completo por parte de los observadores
independientes